hello everybody and welcome to part 6 of
let's play from dust we left off we just
started the first village in this desert
here and I learned that there are
Springs hidden all around and apparently
I need water to pop up so I'll try to
find Springs la dee da dee da nothing
nothing nothing below alright
nope nothing there useless something
something
get me something ah
something nope no whole lot of nothing
whole bunch in nothing let me get one of
my guys to go up there so that looks
interesting
Oh God uh mice and there's not enough of
it around all right
go there one guy go here oh yeah get
that right up in it go man go Yuda man
Oh get it yeah oh yeah oh yeah you got
it whoa that's weird don't know what
you're doing but keep it up guy you know
about an I do all right where am I going
I gotta find a spring I know there's a
spring somewhere here what do you need
help what could you possibly need help
with oh I see all right jeez you can't
climb a little bit man wimpy wimpy
people apparently you can hold back a
gigantic wall of water but you can't
climb a mountain
ah all right what do we got here
spacebar why spacebar
all right let's see what he wants me
person he is
oh what's up what did you drag me up
here for Oh a new story I don't even
know what those stories are for so Oh
back off well I must have found a spring
oh I did I see it I see it there it is
boot let everybody oh boy
oh did I just cause a problem I think I
did oh boy oh no oh no oh no gotta find
a place for it to channel uh I know wait
it seems to be stopping is it stopping
no no it's not stopping needs need to
find channel channel channel all this
too much too much not don't gather okay
alright there we go there we go kind of
nicely River for me
Oh have I mentioned how cool that is I
just made a river well I mean no
actually a river made itself that's even
cooler man look at it go
Wow does that one little spring man you
are good guy Wow alright there we go
there's gushing water going somewhere
this this is probably gonna be a problem
if I just let this go unchecked so but I
guess it's draining somewhere okay but
this is like a bowl this is gonna be a
problem soon oh yeah it is definitely
gonna be a problem so I I don't know I
think I better give my guys a little
more help during
I've build it up for protection and then
you know move forward all right Oh
evaporate then my help I'm worried that
if I stop that stream then this whole
thing is gonna dry up and all the
vegetation go and dive into education
oh I cannot talk oh how did I even get
started doing this or help you why why
what do you need help with oh I see that
that's a legitimate reason I'll give you
that one
how about that for that help go come on
dude oh man there's such wimps deal with
it
all right fine I guess I won't mock you
mercilessly Oh No Oh found a scrape on
the screen don't need a stream there the
last thing I need
all right say the water staying there
though that's cool
all right you're good Oh where's it
coming from
Oh oh boy okay I think I stopped it but
I got a nice little lake now that's kind
of cool hello I'm gonna do with it
oh yeah built that village bang those
drums get it owned make some babies bang
that drum hello baby back like I said
before the the level of detail going in
and out is amazing cuz I'm like way way
out here and then I can just Boop right
back to him and he is still very
detailed like he's got individual
fingers individual toes even and you can
tell his skin has skin tone
that's amazing amazing amazing not to
mention all the physics but I need to
stop rambling about how much I like the
technical aspects of this game ah
Springs brings bringing oh no no no oh
damn this lake is getting out of control
I need to channel it I need to channel
it
I can't channel it there that's the only
way in between the two I get a channel
it this way all right let's see um
distinguished voice of the Asians you
have spread the palms he'll cross half
this territory all right
cool go me oh no none of the spring ah
stop with the springs okay
go try to dig a come on gimme gimme
Oh gimme no not another spring god
they're everywhere
can I know I can evaporate well that
might be useful okay this is do BOPE
evaporate okay whoa
is that evaporating everything oh wow it
did wow it did holy cow holy guacamole
all right where's this last telephone oh
wow that seems hard to get to get it
sand it up maybe just try to get sand
from places that are already going to
flow downwards if I find a stream
all right there we go
good good good almost more more more
more more MORE okay no not water tiniest
a bit of water tiny to be extreme there
not pick it right up sorry
Go Go my minions Oh No oh that's bad
that's bad doc I can't gotcha
ah no no no no no no no I still see you
ah what the hell no good that's more
like it
good job oh no no ah
they're everywhere oh my goodness ah how
is this even a desert there's literally
like an unlimited number amount of water
everywhere I don't even see how it can
be a problem how this is arid at all oh
man okay anyway moving on moving on now
that I've averted that little crisis
I got a stream somewhere I don't see it
though more more MORE all right can you
do it guys are you okay you need my help
I'm here for you yep yep yep there you
go good job good job
oh wow that is an ocean starting how how
does this happen I don't know there's
some mystical forces of work oh that's
gonna be a problem
Oh yep
vengo I'm the winner
alright but there's got to be some more
stuff I feel like I'm blowing through
these levels way too quickly like I get
to 100% vegetation and that's it I guess
alright gonna let that grow but that
needs a little water so let's give it
just a little bit sorry pressing the
wrong button loop sploosh sploosh that
enough oh yeah grow up oh sorry sorry
guy sorry about that
water water water I'm just trying to
make the vegetation grow I'm not really
intending to kill you but just trying to
make the water grown earth with the
water grow the vegetation grow
what's under here is this a rock yeah
what is it what I get closer water tree
gorges on water and reacts to heat by
Anthony emptying its liquid in a single
burst what the heck alright
that's something let's try that out
Stewart
uh-huh okay I'm not getting it I don't
know I don't know I don't know all right
where are we going
oh dear oh no I got evaporate the water
again okay go
people go go go go go oh don't don't say
you need to help man as a long walk is
this the same one we came in from no
there wasn't one that you came in it was
just there all right anyway not quite at
a hundred percent vegetation gotta get a
little more all right there we go grow
grow I am the Lightbringer that was a
lame lame battle cry I'll be the worst
superhero ever oh man you guys are slow
slow slow slow
come on actually they're not even gonna
make it in time
I got to cut it here thank you guys so
much for watching and I will see you
guys in part seven of let's play from
dust bye bye